bonsoir à claude blanchemaison on attend
la locution d'emmanuel mâcon qui a pris
un petit peu de retard depuis la cance
mais ya quand même eu des déclarations
avant donc à la tenue de ce sommet dont
une qu'on retiendra la turquie n'est
plus un partenaire a dit le président
français est ce qu'on est toute blanche
maison un tournant le torchon brûle
officiellement entre les deux pays je
crois que dans les déclarations qui ont
été faites avant le début de la
conférence et dans les échos qu'on en a
il faut retenir la tribune que le
premier ministre grec a publié cet
après-midi dans le journal le monde une
tribune assez équilibrée au bout du
compte dans lequel dans laquelle
monsieur vi de saut takis effectivement
indique que la situation est grave que
les propos belliqueux de monsieur arts
de vannes qui dure depuis maintenant un
certain temps sont inacceptables que ces
propos sont tenus à l'écart de la grèce
et à l'égard de shit mais aussi à
l'égard de l'union européenne dans son
ensemble est d'ailleurs l'union
européenne se solidarise avec ses états
membres que sont la grèce et et chypre
alors monsieur vite sont acquises dans
dans cette tribune et je pense qu'il a
repris cette démonstration tout à
l'heure cet après midi qui est encore en
train de la développer
indique que dans le fond si la turquie
veut éviter l'imposition de nouvelles
sanctions
lors du conseil européen du 24 et du 25
septembre prochain
eh bien il faut qu'elle arrête ses
explorations pétrolières dans la zone
contestée zone qui se trouve entre l'île
de crète qui fait partie de la grèce et
chypre qui est un état donc indépendant
et zone contestée par conséquent que la
grèce considère comme faisant partie de
ses eaux territoriales
donc il faut que le navire qui fait
actuellement de l'exploration pétrolière
dans cette zone
en fait des explosions pour voir quelle
est la résonance et s'il ya des poches
hydrocarbures se retire de cette zone
et puis que monsieur erdogan cesse de
proférer des propos belliqueux à tout
propos et à tout moment
d'ailleurs il est à ciseler monsieur
erdogan
parce qu'à part l'accord qu'il a conclu
avec le gouvernement de tripoli et il
n'a pas beaucoup d'amis qui le
soutiennent ouvertement dans cette
affaire il est un peu seul sur la scène
internationale donc actuellement chacun
se jauge et je pense que dans les quinze
jours qui nous séparent du conseil
européen il faut encore ménagé les une
voie de sortie au premier ministre turc
mais évidemment pour cela il faut qu'il
cesse son agression et qu'il cesse son
comportement belliqueux
alors on le disait quand même la turquie
n'est plus un partenaire a dit le
président français de son côté en quarts
a dit voilà que ces propos sont
inacceptables emmanuel macron mettant en
péril
l'europe on a quand même l'impression
que la branche maison d'un dialogue
rompu qui va être difficile à restaurer
dire que monsieur erdogan a toujours
l'habitude de tenir des propos excessifs
il a traité emmanuel macron et les
français de néocolonialistes parce
qu'ils étaient allés aider les libanais
ceci évidemment incomplètement est
complètement irréaliste à face à cela
n'a aucun sens et je pense qu'il
reviendra à la raison
d'ailleurs en turquie un certain nombre
d'éléments est compris dans l'armée
turque considère que les propos et
l'attitude du président sont un peu
aventuriste ce n'était pas le meilleur
moyen d'obtenir gain de cause puisque le
fond de la question c'est qu'un jour il
faudra bien s'asseoir à la table avec
les grecs pour déterminer les limites
des eaux territoriales de la d8 des vins
et des autres et puis comme l'a dit
aussi le premier ministre grec cet après
midi et bien si cette négociation échoue
ou si elle n'a pas lieu parce que
monsieur erdogan ne s'y prête pas et
bien la grèce se portera la faire devant
la cour de justice internationale de la
haye et la cour tranchera
il ya un droit de la mer il ya une
convention sur le droit de la mer par
conséquent les juges internationaux sont
parfaitement en état de trancher ce
différend
alors on attendait on le disait en effet
le mettrons son allocution en tout cas
pour 19h30
il ya du retard 1 40 minutes ça laisse
présager
des négociations difficiles selon vous à
quoi doit-on s'attendre à l'issue de ce
sommet à 7
ça n'est pas un conseil de guerre
dirigée contre contre la turquie
c'est une réunion diplomatique
évidemment chacun exprime ses positions
l'objectif est le même c'est de faire en
sorte que monsieur erdogan rentrer dans
le droit chemin et et qu'il respecte
l'état de droit international et qu'il
cesse ses propos belliqueux à tout
moment et pour cela évidemment il ya
plusieurs méthodes
il ya les sanctions et puis il ya le
dialogue est probablement que cet après
midi l'italie et l'espagne
on compte indiqué qu'il ne fallait pas
rompre les canaux du dialogue et qu'il
fallait renforcer sans doute la position
de l'union européenne de la grèce et de
chypre mais aussi probablement proposé
un dialogue avec monsieur erdogan est en
effet lui montrer le chemin du d'un
retour à une situation normale
alors il le suivra le suivre à part et à
ce moment là il faudra en effet à
réévaluer la situation
l'union européenne a deux semaines avant
le conseil européen ces deux semaines
vont certainement être cruciales pour
l'avenir pour l'avenir des relations
avec la turquie alors si relation comme
vous le savez sont des relations qui
sont assez fortes puisque la turquie est
le cinquième client de l'union
européenne sur le plan commercial
la turquie est dans une situation d'une
union douanière avec avec l'union
européenne et la turquie bénéficie d'une
aide préadhésion puisque même si on a
parle plus beaucoup
la perspective plus ou moins lointaines
étaient que la turquie pourrait un jour
adhérer à l'union européenne sa
spéculative est en train de s'estomper
mais l'aide près des ions demeure
étrange de cette adhésion a été
suspendue l'année dernière ce qui avait
déjà eu une première sanction
on pourrait imaginer en effet si les
choses tournaient mal qu'une autre
partie de cette aide à des prêts
adhésion soit suspendu on verra au
niveau du conseil européen quelle sera
la position allemande
moi je ne doute pas que
ce soir ou demain matin monsieur macron
rendra compte des débats de cet
après-midi 17 pays méditerranéens et
sept pays du sud de l'union européenne
d'une part à charles michel
le président du conseil européen et
d'autre part à angela merkel qui puisque
le fait l'allemagne qui est actuellement
exerce la présidence de l'union
européenne et le rendra compte en sans
doute leur indiquant à son avis quelles
sont les possibilités d'avancer dans
quel est dans quelle voie le conseil
européen pourra se diriger dans deux
semaines merci un clodo blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales